[Music]
hey everybody its Joanna here again and
we're back for another workout class now
before I start if you haven't yet joined
our field daily challenge be sure to do
so because you can still join the
challenge do the 1 minute daily workout
and stand a chance to win the all new
Fitbit Versa with 199 USD ok you don't
want to miss be missing out on this so
be sure to do the challenge one minute
every single day upload your video onto
Instagram hashtag field daily challenge
and tag us fill dot app alright so
today's workout is a call focus workout
we want to work on your core strength
combined with core cardio so it will be
two exercises for each circuit ok the
first workout will be a core strength
workout and the second one will be a
cardio based workout but it will be
focusing on your core strength each
workout will be for 40 seconds long with
20 seconds rest in between and we want
to do the two workouts back-to-back
alright so before we get started let's
get our body warmed up and now I want
you to start by doing inchworm with
shoulder tap okay
so step right at the edge of your mat
start by standing shoulder width apart
toes pointed forward and slowly lower
your body down inch forward stretch out
your hamstring get into a plank tap left
and right and slowly step back okay just
to get your body warmed up remember to
keep your legs straight stretch your
hamstrings out again inch forward keep
your leg straight strong solid plank tap
and slowly back up nice again give me
two more strong plank we will be using
all these movements in the workout as
well up and now back down tap and get
back up nice
now what a way to do is get into a high
plank position step your left foot out
your left palm and stretch open up
against that back into
and alternate good just stretching the
entire body as well as working on your
core strength as well good stretch it
out step back open up look straight
ahead and feel your back muscles being
stretched out as well nice keep going
open up few more step back open give me
one more on each side
step back open and now get into a plank
what I wanted to do is start in a low
plank and just rock forward and back
just to engage your core muscles forward
and back keeping your back flat and your
core tight okay good and now deep side
to side keeping your back flat again do
not Pike up this is wrong okay so back
flat core tight and just deep side to
side very good and now slowly stand back
up and I want you to just twist side to
side okay move your hips point your toes
and just gently twist side to side good
shake it out roll your shoulders if you
need to just roll it out big circles and
[Music]
forward so the first circuit it will be
spider-man and also a mountain climber
okay so before we start let me just show
you the workout so start in high plank
with spider-man what a way to do is
bring your knee to your elbow and crunch
feel your obliques working and crunch
okay with mountain climbers again in a
high plank drive your knees close to
your chest alright so these are the two
workouts and we'll be starting in five
seconds
each workout will be for 40 seconds long
20 seconds rest back to the word second
workout and we go back again alright
ready let's go high plank
two spider-men and just tap okay as much
as you can
bring your
to your elbow good so left knee to left
elbow right knee to right elbow keeping
a strong solid plank very nice keep
going
remember push into the floor relax your
neck relax your shoulders
do not hunch okay push into the floor
keep going
last few more and just rest it out
second workout melts and clamber so this
is your core cardio workout first is
your core strength second your core
cardio K so if you need to shake it out
a little bit and we want to get into
mountain climbers so high plank okay
drive your knees into your chest let's
go climb and drive it in again pushing
into the floor relaxing your shoulders
and really feeling your coal working
drive it in breathe in and breathe out
close in point your toes tiptoe you're
halfway there keep going
breathe in and breathe out keeping your
back flat and crime good now let's speed
it up slightly okay few more strong core
strong upper body good rest it out back
to the first workout spider-man again
okay so you know the workout check that
you are always engaging the right
muscles and in the right form okay so
shake it out a little bit get back into
a high plank we're starting with
spider-man first ready let's go
spider-man elbow touching your knee good
tap
and tap look straight down okay
do not look straight ahead gently gaze
down and breathe in and breathe out
whoo you should also feel your upper
body burning at the same time push into
the floor
strong core your core is not just your
abs but your lower back muscles as well
last one and rest is next workout
you know this mountain climber all right
start in - okay as much as you can push
yourself go for speed but maintaining a
flat back all right three seconds two
seconds let's get into it and let's go
drive it in keep your knees soft your
elbows soft look straight pace our
breathing breathe in and out
crunch and feel your core crunching drop
it in keep going
halfway there you are strong okay
drive it in last few more speed it up as
fast as you can
ha and you're getting a one-minute
breath so briefing
Razak take this time to breathe rest
keep yourself hydrated what yourself so
what we are moving on to the second
circuit so the workouts are really short
rest time is really short as well hence
I want you to give me your best effort
and push yourself okay
remember to breathe in breathe out bring
your heart rate back down slightly the
next two workouts will be neat app for
your core strength and bear jacks for
your core cardio K so what need to have
what I wanted to do is get into all
fours and just lift your body up and a
way to just tap the opposite side okay
so as much as you can keep your body in
a static and steady position as for bear
jacks same thing or first lift your body
up Jack out and jack in back into all
fours
alright ready let's go all fours up and
just tap do not swing your body
this is drunk a static position and just
tap good so engage your core keeping
your back flat suck your belly in and
tap the opposite side good
tap and tap good whoo maintaining the
awful position good keep tapping keep
reaching
your knees should just be about two
inches off the floor so not too high up
and not too low good now shake it all
it's a bit bare Jax this is a cardio so
I want you to drive your heart rate up
all right 10 seconds rest breathe
remember to always breathe do not hold
your breath shake your arms out a little
bit ready get back into all fours and
check it out bring it in crunch in bend
your knees
crunch in good there you go so it's not
straight legs
coming in it's about bending your knees
and crunching your abs out white jacks
and in good keep going check it in out
in and out nice crunch you should also
feel your leg muscles working here huh
feel your heart rate see your sweat
dripping keep going few more guys few
more you're always there huh now we're
going back to the first workout knee tap
all right breathe and then followed by
bear jacks okay that's the second
circuit let's get back down check it all
it's a bit let's go up tap and tap good
reach and reach steady nice just about
two inches off the floor back flat look
straight down keep it flat keep it
strong suck your belly in tighten your
ass feel the burn on your abs and your
quads as well tap it reach and reach
get it keep going
last few more and rest oh I am already
dripping and sweating Barry Jack's okay
let's bring your heart rate back up and
you will get a break after this ah so
check it out if at all you feel like you
need to keep yourself hydrated go ahead
and grab yourself a sip of water if not
let's go Jack in and out good out of him
remember the pace of breathing listen to
your heart listen to your body feel your
muscles working engage fully with your
body give you that burn keep going guys
I can feel your pain okay ten more
seconds
you're almost there push it must be more
aah oh my god
rested not ten minutes down two circuits
done two more circuits to go take this
time to breathe wipe your sweat keep
yourself hydrated
all right guys you should be sweaty I'm
feeling so at the I'm feeling good two
more seconds right let's bring the
challenge up even more the first core
strength workout it's a reverse plank so
sit on your butt fingers points up
forward what I want to do is get onto
your heels bring your butt down lift it
up into reverse plank bring it back down
lift it up and squeeze okay that's your
first workout second workout is a
straight knee hop so in a plank position
stop behind start in a high downward dog
what I want to do is keep your leg
straight hop in hop up hop in hop out so
it's just a really small hop but you
will really feel it on your car okay so
let's start with reverse plank on your
heels down up squeeze down up and
squeeze there you go dip up and squeeze
look straight ahead squeeze if your body
is shaking that is absolutely fine that
is just your muscles being engaged and
working together okay
it is absolutely normal you're not doing
anything wrong in fact you're doing it
right good squeeze up squeeze the gluts
for your core squeeze for your lower
back and relax now switch to the
opposite side and remember as much as
you can your goal is to keep your leg
straight by keeping your leg straight
that's how you will be engaging your
core even more even if it's just a small
hop forward that is absolutely fine okay
so downward dog ready and now let's go
hop in out in out in and out good small
hop as much as you can keep your leg
straight when you hop in find your abs
like your butt up and hop back good pick
your butt up and back keep your feet
together and keep your knees soft okay
straight legs good hop in and up this is
not an easy workout beginners you can
always start by bending your knees
slightly hop in as you progress you will
be able to hop further in okay keep
hopping in and out oh good job
second round through let's go let's get
back into reverse plank okay breathe
take this time to just catch your breath
alright so sit on your butt fingers
pointed forward keep your shoulders
relaxed push yourself into the floor and
let's go on your heels and up point your
toes and look straight ahead very good
up and point down up and down and
squeeze squeeze the gluts feel the
stretch
and engagement on your lower back as
well and hoin good keep going whoa my
body is shaking
haha few more point oh my god I can also
feel all my hamstrings keep going last
one up and down ah now let's get back
into straight knee hops alright are you
ready
you got this okay this time push
yourself and try to hop a little further
alright let's go in a high plank up and
go up in up in as you hop bend your
knees slightly okay
hop in out in and out good keep going
small hops
engage those core muscles and out
stretch out and remember to press your
palms into the floor you are almost
there guys
almost there strong core I can see a
sweat dripping I can see you burning I
feel your burn a few more one more pop
in rest it out you know what that means
three circuits down one more to go one
more take this time to breathe
grab some water wipe your sweat and end
the final circuit strong oh my god every
time I work out I'm just super sweaty
and because I want to feel what you feel
therefore I like to do the workout life
together with you right finest circuit
okay the first workout is going to be a
knee to V tucks
so again sit on your butt what I want to
do is point your fingers forward give me
a nice knee tuck and to a v-tach okay so
knee to V good and we want to end with a
crazy cardio grayness so start in a high
plank left food to your left pump
hop into the right and hop into the left
okay
cardio blaster alright let's start with
your core strength knee to V tux so sit
without fingers pointed forward let's go
knee tuck V good again relax your upper
body
use your core muscles your lower abs
your other apps to drive the movements
this is not an easy workout this is one
of my favorite core workouts because it
is extremely effective beginners if this
is too hard you can always rest drop
your heels
tuck it in crunch it drop
slightly tuck it in and crunch it okay
ten more seconds in and straight legs in
and straight one more and last one and
drop it good
my legs are jello absolutely jello okay
find a [ __ ] are you growing us alright
let's die together right let's go this
is a love-hate relationship let's get a
high plane
let's go left right good so find your
pace keep breathing
and every time you hop open up your
chest and look up okay good
halfway there bend your elbows slightly
find that momentum and hop into the
workout oh I feel your burn man ten more
seconds left
do not stop you can slow down but do not
stop the workout okay last one and rest
it out right knee to vito's okay let's
go back into me final find a final
workout okay
let's do this man you'll find a circuit
we got less than two minutes let's go
knee
tuck it in and crunch it I can remember
beginners what you can do is you can tap
on the floor bring it in tap it down
bring it up and tap it down okay
everybody needs a starting point let's
go up and in good ten more seconds left
up in whoa I can feel your burn guys two
more do not stop right now last one one
more ah ah oh my god what am i doing to
myself and what am i doing to you guys
seriously why do we do this because we
went to sweat we want to increase our
stamina and I promise you you'll feel
damn good groin s last workout I feel
your burn he would get a good cool down
after this less talking let's go hop in
and out listen to your body here listen
to your breath engage focus find your
focus what is it that you want for
yourself this year what is your goal
take this moment to think about that and
keep pushing yourself okay
you can't slow down but remember do not
stop give me two more on each side one
more last one and you're done my hair is
going over the roof again guys remember
if you want to you can win yourself a
Fitbit versa it will be able to track
your heart rate how much calories you
burn how hard you're working and it will
also lock all your workouts okay see
this way it's real and I want it to be
sweaty just like me let's just cool down
let's bring our heart rate back down
let's just get into a child's
[Music]
and just bring a highway back down
now here's the tip okay in order to
bring a heart rate back down your goal
is to bring it below 100 heartbeat per
second okay that's when you know that
your body has groove down right now I
want you to just stretch up reach up
okay
just stretch up just stretch your arms
yes it is a core workout but you've used
a lot of your arms as well and just
release it shake it out breathe in
stretch up good and I'll just hands on
your head just twist and on the other
side twist and just look forward okay
now I wait to sit on the mat both legs
forward bring your right leg across your
left leg left arm across your right leg
and just look as far back as you can
twist and feel your obliques your upper
back your lower back being stretched out
and now fold both legs so left leg on
the bottom right leg right on top stack
on top of each other and just reach and
stretch forward and you should feel the
stretch on your glutes
very good guys bring your hubby back
down and now let's switch sides okay so
both legs forward now left leg across
the right leg right hand on top of the
left and twist and look as far back as
possible
relax remember to keep your body
straight do not hunch this way okay keep
your body straight and twist and now
laughs right on bottom left on top and
reach forward
[Music]
good and now just sit up shake it out a
little bit roll your shoulders shake it
out very very whoo well done
do this core strength and [ __ ] hard work
out consistently and for you to see
better results don't forget to download
my new fitness app few on the app store
all go to feel like calm and combine
this workout with other daily life
classes we have on the app and you will
also stand a chance to win the all new
Fitbit versa as well as the Fitbit
charge 3 just by signing up and joining
the field daily challenge don't forget
to like this video give this video a
thumbs up share this video on and
subscribe to my youtube channel for a
lot more workout videos recipes and also
fitness tips are the best and I know
that you will be starting 2019 strong